[Música]
bienvenidos a covid-19 la semana en
América el espacio de France 24 en qué
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas en relacionadas con la
pandemia covid-19 a continuación algunos
de los temas que trataremos en este
programa
hablaremos por supuesto de la nueva
variante Omicron detectada en Sudáfrica
ya es considerada por la OMS como una
variante de preocupación con una gran
cantidad de mutaciones que tiene un
mayor riesgo de reinfeccion frente a
otras variantes que podemos hacer cómo
preparar nos vamos a analizar el tema de
unos minutos en nuestra consulta con el
Dr Pérez hablaremos o también de la
situación en Perú y en Ecuador países en
donde los casos de contagio han
reportado en los últimos días las
autoridades de ambos países se han
reforzado los sistemas de vacunación en
los planes de vacunación en estos países
en Ecuador ya está disponible por
ejemplo en la tercera dosis mientras que
en Perú algunos científicos locales han
detectado hasta 30 mutaciones de la
variante Delta y hablaremos por supuesto
de Europa que sigue en alerta ante el
reciente pico de contagio de covid 19
por ejemplo Eslovaquia estableció dos
semanas de confinamiento y Portugal qué
es el líder de vacunación en la Unión
impuso medidas que van antes y después
de las fiestas de diciembre decir
Navidad y Año Nuevo Alemania ya supero
las 100000 muertes por cuenta del
coronavirus veremos cómo está el
panorama en el viejo continente con esto
pues damos inicio entonces el programa
lo hacemos como es habitual con las
cifras viendo cómo está el panorama
general del covid-19 en nuestro
continente comenzamos en Estados Unidos
en donde hay más de 48000000 de casos
desde que comenzó la emergencia
sanitaria en ese país dos fallecidos ya
superan los
775000 Panamá reporta para el cierre de
esta semana más de
476000 casos y más de 7300 personas han
fallecido allí por cuenta del covid-19
en Argentina contabilizan más de 5.3
millones de casos y los fallecidos
superan los 116000 € guay tiene más de
398000 casos se aproxima ya los 400.000
los fallecidos superan los 6000 Brasil
cierra esta semana con más de 20
millones de casos y más de 613000
personas han fallecido en ese país
suramericano
la nueva variante de covid-19 detectada
por primera vez en Sudáfrica ya tiene
nombre se llama Omicron y es considerada
por la OMS como una variante de
preocupación por este motivo algunos
países como Estados Unidos Canadá y
también algunos países de la Unión
Europea
anunciaron que impondrán restricciones a
todos los viajeros procedentes de
Sudáfrica y de otros países vecinos de
esa zona del continente africano
mientras tanto en Sudáfrica la mayoría
de las provincias de ese país ya están
reportando casos de esta variante aún
así el gobierno indico que las
restricciones impuestas a nivel
internacional hacia los vuelos y
pasajeros procedentes de Sudáfrica son
completamente
injustificadas
de preocupación así catálogo la
Organización Mundial de la Salud a la
nueva variante del coronavirus a la que
denomino Omicron
asesoramiento técnico sobre la evolución
del virus se reunirá periódicamente
sobre Omicron se necesitarán días o
semanas para que se lleven a cabo
algunos de esos estudios tan pronto como
tengamos más información haremos pública
pero es importante saber que hay muchas
cosas que pueden hacer para protegerse y
proteger a sus seres queridos aunque los
estudios apenas empiezan los expertos ya
han alertado sobre la posibilidad de que
Omicrón tenga una mayor transmisibilidad
y la capacidad de sortear la respuesta
inmunitaria de las vacunas tras el
anuncio la Unión Europea opto por
restringir viajes desde y hacia el
epicentro de la nueva variante todos los
vuelos a estos países deberán
suspenderse y se mantendrán suspendidos
hasta que exista un entendimiento claro
de los alcances de esa variante y los
viajeros que estén retornando desde
estas regiones deberán respetar
estrictas reglas de cuarentena Sudáfrica
nude en reaccionar a la medida
catalogando la de injustificada
este es un mal enfoque se ha equivocado
va en contra de los estándares de la OMS
[Música]
simplemente tenemos la sensación de que
algunos líderes de países están
encontrando chivos expiatorios para
hacer frente a un problema mundial
en Bélgica los laboratorios reportaron
el primer caso de contagio por la
variante sudafricana se trata de un
ciudadano que regreso de Egipto el
pasado 11 de noviembre mientras que el
continente europeo enfrenta una de las
olas más fuertes
vamos a conversar con el Dr Carlos
Eduardo Pérez medico infectologo y
también científico de France 24 ya está
con nosotros para nuestra habitual
consulta buenas noches bienvenidos
[Música]
Santiago l'alta la alarma que se están
adelante es porque acumula mutaciones
que ya conocíamos del virus y algunas de
estas mutaciones cambian la
transmisibilidad la sea más efectiva
hola virulencia decir que enferma más en
esta variante se reúnen varias de las
mutaciones de 8 linajes en uno solo y
por eso es que llama la atención porque
obviamente a tener mayor
transmisibilidad ya estamos por
verificar si va a tener mayor virulencia
por resistencia las vacunas precisamente
entonces le pregunto qué significa que
tiene múltiples mutaciones y esto
entonces qué características
particulares le podría dar a esta
variante y cuáles de estas
características son de preocupación para
nosotros
las mutaciones son pequeños cambios que
hay en las proteínas que cambian la
conformación de una proteína más grande
en todas las mutaciones se acumulan
naturalmente en todos los virus como
también nosotros y todas las mutaciones
se van acumulando lo que sucede es que
sean mutaciones de las proteínas giga
del virus que aumentan la
transmisibilidad y algunas otras que
aumentan la virulencia o algunas otras
que son
esta variante reúne todas esas malas
mutaciones en un sol en un solo virus en
un solo linaje virus y esa
característica acumular muchas
mutaciones en un solo pues lo que llama
la atención
covid-19 qué particularidades tiene este
país o en la forma como el virus y ha
movido en este país para que dos
variantes hayan comenzado allí y se
habían expandido al mundo entero
digamos que una de las particularidades
también es que en Sudáfrica tienen una
rete
investigación genomica bastante
importante entonces tienen capacidad de
encontrar estas mutaciones distintas en
otros países probablemente puede estar
circulando en otros países sino no
tiendas herramientas tecnológicas para
poderlo identificar obviamente en el
continente africano hay una simetría
social una falsa las vacunas es el
continente con menos tasa de vacunación
y ya sabemos que mientras haya personas
no vacunadas que el virus se está
replicando
esto yo creo que la combinación de tener
una situación de poca vacunación alta
circulación suma una vigilancia genomica
realmente es muy buena en Sudáfrica y
por eso es que bien típica en
rápidamente estas mutaciones entonces
según en estos dos aspectos para decir
que su africana pero creo que uno de los
grandes problemas estigmatizar una
región por estas mutaciones que hicieron
bien su trabajo y la puedan identificar
puedes alianzas parte del mundo y no se
han dado claro también es una forma de
no estoy matizar es que a estas
variantes se les ha dado un nombre para
no decir la variante de X o sepáis para
que nos estigmatizan las personas que
son de estas regiones doctor punto
importante las vacunas que tenemos
actualmente en circulación que nos han
servido para hacer frente a las
variantes que teníamos hasta el día de
hoy que se ha ido a conocer esta noticia
y está alerta nivel internacional
es suficiente estas vacunas la tercera
dosis dosis de refuerzo que ya está en
marcha en muchos países puede ser
suficiente para hacer frente a esta
nueva variante
está luz es el gran interrogante y por
eso cuando se coloca qué es una variante
de preocupación ya no interés si no hay
preocupación es porque se emplean los
estudios clínicos con las vacunas que se
están haciendo actualmente
definitivamente estar vacunado a ser
mucho mejor que no estar vacunada
digamos no hacer el mismo terreno para
coronavirus de una persona que esté
monita y sobre todo reforzar la
inmunización
cuando una persona no tiene ningún tipo
de Ciencias para los coronavirus
entonces no sabemos todavía y es lo que
te hace estar en estas próximas semanas
cómo es el comportamiento este linaje
con las vacunas actuales y con los
refuerzos pero sin duda las personas no
vacunadas van a ser el gran proceso de
transmisibilidad y no tengo ninguna duda
que las vacunas en alguna medida nos van
a servir para exterminar que tanto si
mucho poquito o moderado es lo que vamos
a desarrollar en él quien complemento
eso que usted dice doctor diciendo que
la farmacéutica moderna dice que va a
desarrollar un refuerzo de la vacuna que
tiene aquí para que pueda combatir esta
nueva variante cobitis en vaya poco a
poco y reacciones en la industria
también en la Agencia de Salud de la
Unión Europea dice que hay un riesgo de
que Omicron se propague rápidamente en
Europa el riesgo de alto a muy alto
muchas gracias Doctor por esta consulta
quién covid-19 la semana en América
gracias por estar con nosotros vamos
ahora a ver cómo ha avanzado la
vacunación en nuestro continente les
presentamos a continuación el porcentaje
de la población con esquemas de
vacunación completo demos un vistazo a
las cifras de EEUU allí el
57,88% de los ciudadanos ya tiene el
esquema completo México cierra esta
semana con el
49,61% si le llegó al
83,42% Uruguay el
76,14% mientras que Colombia termino
esta semana con el
46,99% de la población con el esquema
completo
vamos a hablar ahora de México que es
uno de los países que cuenta con el
portafolio de vacunas anti covid más
amplio del mundo este país a inoculado a
sus ciudadanos con vacunas de facer
cansino AstraZeneca Sputnik Sinovac
Janssen y moderna en efecto los
contagios y hospitalizaciones han ido en
descenso allí en México y continúan a la
baja en toda la república mexicana
aunque las autoridades advirtieron esta
semana que podría presentarse un repunte
de contagios en el corto plazo
buenas noticias para México los
contagios por covid-19 van en descenso
por 17 semanas consecutivas
algo que se ha visto reflejado en las
hospitalizaciones y decesos en esta
semana nos tenemos una reducción
nuevamente más cuantiosas que la semana
pasada qué fue de menos 8 abrimos
nuevamente con menos 17 esta trayectoria
es esperable en cuando ya se tiene
intensidad de pedir mi camino lo mismo
vemos en el indicador de la ocupación
hospitalaria se siguen desocupando las
unidades Kobe y no tan bien como lo
hemos dicho es muy importante que en
algunas entidades federativas ya empezó
a ocurrir que pasan algunos días sin que
se presente una sola defunción por cobis
lo cual es sumamente alentador y habla
también de la del beneficio de la
vacunación y la reducción sostenida de
la epidemia la ocupación media de camas
generales se mantienen 17 % y el uso de
camas de terapia intensiva en 13 % aún
así un estudio realizado por la
Universidad Johns Hopkins revelo que es
el cuarto país con más muertes por covid
19 detrás de Estados Unidos Brasil y la
India y es la decimoquinta nación en
número de contagios confirmados sin
embargo en la semana pasada el
secretario de Salud Jorge Alcocer alertó
sobre la posibilidad de una cuarta ola
aún así el gobierno mexicano no tiene
planes de imponer mayores exigencias a
sus ciudadanos
nosotros no vamos
nunca
a
volver obligatoria
la vacunación
no
porque
nosotros tenemos un pueblo
qué es mucha pieza
te pueblo de México
estamos
en los porcentajes más altos de
vacunación en el mundo
de una población de más de 128000000 de
habitantes más de 76 millones de
personas mayores de edad tienen al menos
una dosis de la vacuna mientras que más
de 64000000 a recibió el esquema
completo el país azteca se encuentra
vacunando a menores de entre 12 y 17
años con comorbilidades y anunció
recientemente que inmunizar a todos los
adolescentes de entre 15 y 17 años
vamos ahora a dar un vistazo a ver cómo
está la situación en Perú allí en la
ciudad de Lima está Francisco Zacarías
nuestro corresponsal Francisco gracias
por acompañarnos hoy en el programa y un
grupo científico de peruanos en estado
cerca de 30 mutaciones de la variante
del está en ese país sudamericano de qué
se trata
hola Santiago
4 variantes del 19 al mismo tiempo
Francisco también destacado esta semana
allí en Perú es leve aumento de casos
que han presentado algunos distritos en
lima la capital que dicen las
autoridades allí
de la Unidad de Inteligencia y análisis
de datos del sistema sanitario de la
Seguridad Social
Francisco finalmente qué información hay
sobre ese regreso a clases cerca de
95000 colegios en el peruano a regresar
a clases presenciales
Luciano que 95.000 escuelas están
habilitadas para brindar clases
presenciales y semipresenciales antes de
que termine este 2021 será prioridad
alumnos del último año de educación
secundaria contando con más del 87% de
docentes que en territorio peruano
completaron su vacunación contra el
covid-19 el presidente Pedro Castillo
afirmo que el país volver a las clases
presenciales en marzo de 2022 y también
señaló que se afinarán protocolos
sanitarios para que las escuelas sean
espacios seguros para los maestros y los
estudiantes
Francisco muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de Lima
el Ministerio de Salud de Francia
pospuso la puesta en marcha de la Ley
que imponía la obligatoriedad de
vacunarse a los trabajadores de salud en
los territorios de ultramar de Martinica
y Guadalupe en el Caribe esto ante la
violencia y las manifestaciones
ciudadanas en rechazo a esta medida
veamos
las escenas de destrucción vistas estos
días en las islas de Martinica y
Guadalupe obligarán a dar marcha atrás
al gobierno francés el Ministerio de
Salud anunció el congelamiento temporal
de la medida de la vacuna obligatoria a
los trabajadores sanitarios de estas
islas y es que departamentos como el de
Martinica llevan días viviendo protestas
violentas por este motivo en las calles
de la isla se suceden las barricadas y
los comercios saqueados e incluso la
residencia del más alto representante de
la Francia metropolitana fue atacada
[Música]
vamos si la titulación la violencia
proviene del rechazo de una parte de la
población hacia las vacunas en las
últimas horas se han llegado a reportar
ataques con armas de fuego a policías
algo que ha motivado la implantación del
toque de queda desde este jueves y la
condena desde París y
número de casos lo hemos visto a Lola a
lo largo de esta semana como está
comportándose el sistema de salud de
allí
hola qué tal Santiago en las últimas
tres semanas de SMS a aumentado los
casos positivos pasando del 4 al 9 %
llegando a 300 casos a la semana según
cifras oficiales la situación sanitaria
original que se repite el escenario
demanda reclamación espera mayor
ocupación hospitalaria saturación de las
unidad de cuidados intensivos inclusive
en las ciudades de Quito y Guayaquil los
contagios se Azucena último feriado por
el Día de los Difuntos y fiestas
ocurridas en el país en los meses de
octubre y noviembre administra de salud
Ximena Garzón aseguro que los casos son
de personas que no están vacunadas o
solo tienen una sola dosis de
inoculación las organizaciones médicas
el país alerta que se debe fortalecer
los controles sanitarios a propósito del
retorno masivo las aulas de clase las
fiestas decembrinas y las aglomeraciones
propias los últimos meses del año en
este país a pesar del Saler está la
situación económica del país no
aguantaría otro confinamiento o paraíso
acciones laborales en Ecuador igual
forma los gremios empresariales
trabajadores y Ejecutivo Nacional
apuntan a la reactivación económica y la
conciencia social cuidarse de contagios
de covid 19 en
Ecuador cuáles son las metas que tiene
el Gobierno al mediano plazo
si el Gobierno Nacional tiene 30 días
aproximadamente para aplicar 6000000
vacunas y lograr así la inmunidad
colectiva durante el mes de septiembre
se había planteado lograr vacunada 85%
de la población es de unos 15000000
personas aproximadamente pero la meta
hasta el momento sólo ha logrado
inmunizar al 68 % de la población lo que
significa once viernes ecuatorianos
residentes en este país andino para ello
se anunció que se fortalecerá la
vacunación en cuatro regiones amazonicas
el país en la que el porcentaje
aplicación es muy bajo más bajo del
comparación el país motivar a las
personas de 24 años era otro reto y aquí
han dejado de acudir a los puntos
aplicación para el químico y se han
echado minga familiares vacunaciones
masivas en colegios universidades y
centros de salud la aplicación de
tercera dosis es otra estrategia que ya
se inició en el país Gustavo y qué datos
hay en cuanto a la tercera dosis cuándo
va a empezar a ser inoculada y quiénes
podrán acceder a ella y cómo van a poder
acceder a ella
que ella se inició la vacunación de las
dosis de refuerzo tercera 2 población de
65 años con enfermedad especiales y a
personal estratégico Ejecutivo anuncio
que a partir del mes de enero toda la
población será inoculada a pesar que no
se conocen los detalles un cronograma la
titular de Salud informó que se
realizará de la misma manera como se
efectuó anteriormente iniciando de mayor
a menor según los rangos de edad el
requisito es que hayan pasado los 6
meses desde la última aplicación de su
segunda dosis y finalmente en otro día
pronunciado es que a partir del primero
de diciembre Ecuador y Colombia
reabrirán el paso formal por sus
fronteras terrestres para ello se
solicita el carnet de vacunación a todo
el que cruzó el paso fronterizo pruebas
de PCR negativa y se integrarán brigadas
médicas entre ambos países para aumentar
así el control sanitario y defender en
la frontera vacunación muchas gracias
Gustavo por este completo reporte desde
la ciudad de Quito nos vamos hasta
Europa dice mantiene la alerta por el
repunte de casos de covid-19 que viene
presentando desde hace ya varias semanas
países como Eslovaquia por ejemplo ya
decidieron confinamiento como ya lo
hicieron hace algunas semanas Letonia y
Austria la situación es particularmente
preocupante en Alemania por el aumento
de los casos y también de los fallecidos
vamos a hacer una ronda con nuestros
corresponsales en Berlín en París y en
Bruselas para conocer los detalles de
las medidas que han impulsado así los
gobiernos y sobre cómo está la situación
veamos
para otra semana muy difícil para
Alemania en su lucha contra la cuarta
ola de la pandemia del coronavirus con
cifras récord de infectados que incluso
superaron los 70000 nuevos contagios en
24 horas el país también superó la marca
de los 100000 muertos por coronavirus
desde que comenzó la pandemia son cifras
muy preocupantes que sin duda aumenta la
presión para que el nuevo gobierno tiene
Berlín tome medidas en el asunto lo más
rápido posible espera que el nuevo
gobierno liderado por el próximo
canciller hola Souls esté en el poder
desde la segunda semana de diciembre las
autoridades aquí en Berlín también está
mirando muy de cerca lo que ocurre en el
país vecino de Austria donde los
contagios continúan en un nivel muy alto
Austria impuso recientemente un
confinamiento y las autoridades envían a
pero también aquí en Berlín están muy
pendientes del posible efecto que pueda
tener ese confinamiento para bajar las
altas tasas de contacto las cifras del
covid-19 preocupan en Francia en esta
quinta ola que según dijo ayer el
ministro de Salud Olivia es mucho más
fuerte que la cuarta que vimos en el
verano ayer hubo más de 33000 nuevos
casos lo que hace una media de 23000
nuevos casos por día en la semana que
acaba de terminar además hay más de 8000
personas hospitalizadas 139 en
reanimación y la tasa de incidencia es
el número de casos por cada 100.000
habitantes supera en 50 de los 101
departamentos franceses los 200 casos
por lo mismo ayer el ministro de Salud
anunció que la tercera dosis era
obligatoria para todos los adultos a
partir del 15 de enero si quieren
conservar su pasaporte sanitario decir
que esa fecha quien tenga más de 7 meses
desde su segunda dosis y no se haya
vacunado por tercera vez perder a ese
pasaporte sanitario también la
mascarilla será obligatorio en todos los
espacios cerrados e incluso abierto
según perfecto así lo desea por ejemplo
en el caso de un mercado navideño las
escuelas elementales ya cerrarán cuando
hay un caso de covid-19 pero en cambio
todos los alumnos serán testeados y
además se establecerá nuevamente los
controles sanitarios en la frontera es
una persona no vacunada para entrar a
Francia necesitará un test PCR de 24
horas si la persona está vacunada
necesita un test de antígenos de 48
horas o un PCR de 72 horas por ahora el
ministro dijo que los niños no van a ser
vacunados los niños de 5 a 11 años sin
embargo ayer la autoría Europea permite
el uso de Fisher para este grupo etario
por lo tanto lo más probable dijo libera
es que los niños sean vacunados el
próximo año
con tasas de vacunación muy desiguales
entre los países de la Unión Europea
están aumentando los casos pero sobre
todo las hospitalizaciones en las
muertes el Centro Europeo de Control y
Prevención de Enfermedades advertido que
se tomen medidas urgentes o de lo
contrario los meses de diciembre y enero
van a ser muy duros por ello recomienda
que se administre una dosis de refuerzo
lo antes posible a toda la población
general pero muy especialmente a los
mayores de 40 años de según las últimas
evidencias las vacunas siguen siendo
eficaces pero sí que se ha observado un
cierto descenso de los anticuerpos unos
meses después de administrarse la pauta
completa de la vacuna por ello la
Comisión Europea ha propuesto que al
cabo de 9 meses caduque el certificado
digital este documento que confirma que
una persona ha sido vacunada por ello
los países europeos tendrán que
actualizar cuanto antes las campañas de
vacunación para esta dosis de refuerzo
aunque ya se ha empezado a administrar
las personas vulnerables en todo caso
las Navidades están a la vuelta de la
esquina pueden aumentar los contactos
sociales por ello muchos países ya han
empezado a tomar duras restricciones
como por ejemplo Bélgica en cualquier
caso también preocupa la variante del
sur de África por ello muchos países
europeos y han decidido prohibir los
vuelos provenientes de esta región
de
Turquía
en 28 días
5000 personas han perdido la vida en
Turquía Ucrania
de 564000 casos y 18000 fallecidos y
cerramos este top con Polonia con más de
435000 casos y más de 5000 fallecidos
íbamos a seguir en Europa para que
veamos y hagamos un alto en Portugal qué
es el país más vacunado de la Unión
Europea con una tasa del
87,78% de sus poco más de 10 millones de
habitantes ya vacunados con todas las
dosis de rigor dependiendo de la vacuna
sin embargo antes de rápido aumento de
casos que está teniendo en buena parte
de la Unión Europea Portugal decidió
tomar medidas preventivas veamos cuáles
son a partir del primero de diciembre
vuelve a ser obligatorio el uso de la
mascarilla será necesario presentar un
certificado de vacunación y serán
exigidas las pruebas de PCR para algunos
casos determinados así mismo habrá
restricciones en el aforo y será
necesario tener un resultado de un texto
un PCR negativo para poder ingresar a
tierras portuguesas a partir de esta
idea del gobierno
ellos van a intentar mantener activa la
industria turística qué es la principal
fuente de ingresos de este país eso sí
después del primero de enero el
teletrabajo va a ser gatorio habrá
cierre de bares y discotecas y se
suspende el regreso a las clases y todo
esto volverá a ser virtual todo esto por
un espacio de 2 semanas es decir las dos
semanas posteriores a las fiestas de
Navidad y Año Nuevo esta es una manera
con la que esperan hacerle un cerco al
virus para las personas que se contagian
durante las fiestas y que luego pues se
queden en casa las dos semanas
siguientes y no contagian a más personas
cambiamos de tema la pandemia y la
necesidad de imponer restricciones como
ya lo hemos visto como por ejemplo la
movilidad del confinamiento en casa
agudizó la violencia de género en el
mundo entero se calcula que cerca del
45% de las mujeres han sufrido violencia
durante los últimos meses igual los
meses más complicados de la pandemia
veamos América Latina vive dos pandemias
en paralelo la primera por covid-19 la
segunda por violencia de género algo que
según un estudio llevado a cabo por la
organización ONU Mujeres que recogió
datos en 13 países detener 2020
incluidos Colombia y Paraguay se
intensificó en todo el mundo desde el
inicio de la pandemia que desencadenó en
un largo confinamiento
bastante desalentador y como lo
definimos deseo lo mujeres lo que ha
ocurrido es una pandemia en la sombra
con la violencia contra la mujer
aumentado muchísimas las llamadas las
denuncias y 45 % de las mujeres
declararon haber sufrido violencia de
género o haber sido testigo de ella un
25 % afirma que los conflictos en sus
hogares han sido más frecuentes mientras
que siete de cada diez mujeres afirman
que el abuso verbal por parte de sus
parejas se ha vuelto más común del
confinamiento
para empezar yo diría que la violencia
contra las mujeres en América Latina y
en Bolivia tiene dimensiones pandémicas
no o sea la violencia misma los
feminicidios por los porros como están
dando es una pandemia que nos está
atacando pero que hay que entenderlo
desde ese punto de vista porque no es
solamente durante la pandemia que ha
sucedido sino que permanentemente se va
presentando
840s no que va del año y un aumento de
más del 28 % en el delito de violación
un alza del 4.9 % frente al mismo
periodo del año pasado los homicidios en
El Salvador se elevaron un 31.25 % en
comparación con 2020 y en Venezuela se
han registrado 200 asesinatos de mujeres
en lo que va del año sin embargo solo el
40% de las mujeres que sufren violencia
de género en el mundo piden ayuda una
problemática que al igual que la
pandemia de covid-19 parece no tener un
fin cercano ahora demos un vistazo otras
noticias relacionadas con el covid-19
destacadas en redes veamos para comenzar
esta publicación de france24.com la
Unión Europea prohíbe en bloque los
viajes a y desde Sudáfrica por la nueva
variante de covid-19 en la medida fue
tomada luego de que algunas naciones de
manera independiente impusieron medidas
y fuera detectado un primer caso en
Bélgica
seguimos en Europa Eslovaquia anuncio
que ir a confinamiento por dos semanas
una noticia que se encuentra también en
france24.com siguiendo los pasos de
Austria el gobierno eslovaco ordeno el
cierre después de registrar el mayor
aumento de casos de covid-19 en solo 24
horas desde el inicio de la emergencia
sanitaria las autoridades indicaron que
en 10 días van evaluar la situación y
miran está paradoja el presidente de
Brasil Jair bolsonaro se opone a los
carnavales de Brasil del 2022 por riesgo
de covid-19 no que era una simple gripe
en el covid-19 presidente bolsonaro el
mandatario dijo que era necesario
mantener a la gente cuidándose en sus
casas debido al avance del covid-19 y
que por lo tanto no debería haber
carnavales sin embargo esta es una
decisión de los gobernadores locales
y esto fue nuestro resumen de noticias
aquí en covid-19 la semana en América
nos volvemos a encontrar la próxima
semana por favor sigan se cuidando
usando el tapabocas lavándose las manos
y viendo France 24 nos vemos hasta
entonces chao
[Música]